Morel historic the much loved teacher
the woman who was 29 weeks pregnant and
lost her life earlier on this week just
around the corner from here
at the center of a murder investigation
inside that building those detectives
have been trying to piece together what
happened and they have been searching
for the partner of morel studdock a man
known as David Yates he has been wanted
he has been missing and detectives have
focused the search for him at the place
where his car was found around 10 miles
north of here in Woodland at mogdoc
Country Park well breaking news in the
last minute or so that police Scotland
have confirmed that a body of a man has
been found in a reservoir at that
Country Park a few miles north of where
we are just now that body has yet to be
formally identified but it is believed
to be 36 year old David Yates they say
in this statement he was wanted in
connection with the murder of morel this
investigation they see remains ongoing
nothing has been published so far to
suggest that anyone else has been
involved in her death so that breaking
news the body thought to be David Yates
the man the partner of morel sturrick
who has been wanted in connection with
this murder a body has been found this
evening it has been a frantic search in
that Woodland area all day we witnessed
police divers entering that water
spending a number of hours scouring the
land around that Park as they tried to
piece together what happened we know
that David yates's car his white car was
discovered on Tuesday and neighbors had
said the last time they had seen Morel
had had a conversation with her was on
Friday of last week she was a much-loved
teacher and that was a school Community
today and morning those pupils coming to
terms with the loss of their much-loved
teacher and they were receiving
psychological help and it has been a day
trying to piece together what happened
and that confirmation in just the last
number of minutes that a body has been
discovered in the search for David Yates
who was wanted in connection with the
murder of his pregnant partner Morel
Studdard